joe biden's radical supreme court
nominee katanji jackson took to capitol
hill yesterday for the first day of her
confirmation hearings and republicans
kicked off the hearings by promising to
take the high road
and then most of the members of this
committee remember the confirmation
hearing of brett kavanaugh
one of the lowest moments in the history
of this committee
where democrats on this committee sat on
allegations didn't refer them to the fbi
didn't ask for investigations hid them
and then leaked them
against the wishes
of the complainant
and we began
a circus that featured spartacus moments
featured such nuts
as michael avenatti
whom cnn breathlessly for some months
described as a possible democratic
presidential candidate that's before
presumably he became a felon in recent
months
judge jackson i can assure you
that your hearing will feature none of
that disgraceful behavior
senator cruz can assure her of that but
i cannot because as i have said many
times already
judge katanji jackson groped me at a
party back in the 80s pj was there and
squee was there and and judge catante
jackson was there and her manhandling of
me has caused tremendous trauma in my
life i i demand to see her seventh grade
yearbook and i have exactly as much
evidence against her as christine ford
and julie swetnick and michael avenatti
had against justice brett kavanaugh
but senate republicans have actually
unearthed some dirt on katanji jackson
that is significantly more damning
senate republicans have evidence that
judge jackson has a soft spot for some
of the worst child abusing criminals in
the country and that she thinks the
constitution is rotten to the core which
is a far bigger problem than any
grab-happy indiscretions katanji jackson
may or may not have perpetrated against
me as a teenager did you like that clip
i hope you did i'm glad you did ring the
bell subscribe get the notifications go
to apple podcast spotify stitcher google
play wherever you get your audio
podcasts subscribe to the michael
knowles show if you would be so kind and
you can head on over right now to
dailywire.com go check out fouchy
unmasked this is my three-part
docu-series on fauci
really never seen before unprecedented
stuff in this series it's doing really
really well so we appreciate everyone
who's watched it go check that out today
dailywire.com we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you